with the number of us coronavirus
infections continuing to rise President
Donald Trump made a rare oval office
address to announce new travel
restrictions to blunt the spread of the
virus to keep new cases from entering
our shores we will be suspending all
travel from Europe to the United States
for the next 30 days
these restrictions will also not apply
to the United Kingdom Trump justified
the strict measures by blaming European
leaders now dealing with a mass outbreak
of cases the European Union failed to
take the same precautions and restrict
travel from China and other hotspots
with financial markets falling and a
rising number of Americans staying home
from work Trump also urged the US
Congress to put in place measures to
provide financial relief if we are
vigilant and we can reduce the chance of
infection which we will we will
significantly impede the transmission of
the virus
u.s. coronavirus infections now number
more than a thousand prompting local
governments around the country to cancel
large public gatherings close schools
and even ban fans from sporting events
late Wednesday the NBA suspended its
season after a Utah Jazz player
contracted the virus and in another
stunning announcement Hollywood
superstar Tom Hanks announced he and his
wife also tested positive in recent
weeks Trump has sought to calm public
fears by downplaying the severity of the
corona virus likening it to the common
flu even as his own public health
officials continue to say just the
opposite I think if you count all the
cases of minimally symptomatic or
asymptomatic infection that probably
brings the mortality rate down to
somewhere around 1% which means it is 10
times more lethal than the seasonal flu
despite this dire prediction
Trump stopped short of declaring a
national emergency a move that would
free up more than forty billion in
emergency funds to help local officials
struggling to contain the virus last
week Congress approved just eight point
three billion for treatment and supplies
just after his arrest the White House
announced President Trump is taking his
own precautions canceling trips to the
US states of Colorado and Nevada
kimberley hellcat al Jazeera the White
House